King Arthur: The Legend of the Sword's disastrous
opening in May 2017 vaulted it to the top
of the list of biggest box office bombs of
the year, earning a measly 14.7 million dollars
in the U.S., against a $175 million budget
— plus marketing costs.
"So what happens now.  You know what happens now.
You're quickly becoming a legend."
Yeah: A legendary flop.
But director Guy Ritchie knows how to make
big, loud, awesome action movies.
Charlie Hunnam is a talented actor on-the-rise
with all the qualities you could want in a
leading man.
Jude Law makes a great villain.
So, by Merlin's beard, how did The Legend
of the Sword go so wrong?
Out of touch
The Legend of the Sword is the latest in a
string of studios trying — and failing — to
put a fresh spin on old stories and properties,
joining Ben Hur, Chips, and The Legend of
Tarzan in the flophouse.
Recycling familiar tales just isn't as profitable
as it once was, unless you're Marvel, DC,
or Disney.
But it wasn't that long ago that Arthurian
legend was a cinematic goldmine.
Just ask the makers of 1981's Excalibur, which
grossed $35 million against an estimated
$11 million budget.
Alas, the times have changed.
Hollywood's last attempt at bringing the legend
to the big screen, 2004's star-packed King
Arthur, was also a widely panned flop, suggesting
modern audiences just no longer have an appetite
for Arthur ...
"Behold!
The man who pulled sword from stone!"
And if you actually were pumped for another
Knights of the Round Table flick, the multiple
delays pushing back the release date back
by a whopping ten months might have killed
your buzz.
TV killed the cinema star
When it comes to stabbing and shouting, we're
spoiled for choice.
Do we really need yet another big screen King
Arthur movie when we've got Game of Thrones
and Vikings on demand?
Television is the new home of the adventure
epic, with hundreds and hundreds of hours
available of the exact same kind of gritty
and bloody entertainment The Legend of the
Sword is offering up.
Fans of swords and sorcery stories won't head
out to the theater for this kind of thing
unless they really feel like they can count
on solid results.
And the years of recasting rumors, with Idris
Elba and Colin Farrell, among many others,
attached to and then dropped from the project,
did not bode well for the movie's final cut.
Thin gruel
The almost entirely male supporting cast in
The Legend of the Sword aren't really fleshed
out characters like the ones fans love in
HBO's epics: they're more like plot devices.
King Arthur's cast does their best with what
they've been given.
But their thinly-written characters have no
real motivation outside of "find Arthur, get
him to wield Excalibur, and make him tell
us what to do."
"Now, when you say, 'We're going to take the
castle,' what does that mean?"
"I thought you said you weren't going to push
me.
C'mon lads, chop chop."
Then there's the mysterious Mage, the only
prominent female character, who only ever
uses her immense power from a safe distance
— secretly — and commands animals to do
her dirty work.
But when the combat gets close, she's quickly
overpowered, which just doesn't track.
Why is she holding back?
All in all, if your characters are a flop,
your movie probably will be, too.
Epic fail
To recap: it's kind of no wonder this loud,
violent, romance-free movie with poorly written
characters bombed on Mother's Day weekend.
It was beaten by the female-centric mother
and daughter comedy Snatched, as well as the
box office invincibility of Marvel and its
Guardians of the Galaxy Volume 2.
Warner Brothers clearly overestimated moviegoers'
hunger for this kind of entertainment, overlooking
a major side effect of today's binge-watching
culture: when it doesn't leave you satisfied,
it leaves you stuffed, and paying twenty bucks
at the box office for another bloated epic
doesn't spell relief.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!